sehen wir heute auch die tiere sind mit
gebracht bevor sie angst habe er hinein
gehen erstmal warum sind wir abhängig
die frage lautete über war warum haben
wir uns so abhängig gemacht ja weil das
das spiel der globalisierung ist der
witz der globalisierung ist dass man
überall das kauft wo es am billigsten
ist sonst gebe es bei tk maxx keine
jeans für 20 euro wir hätten ja auch in
meinem beispielsweise früher
stabilisierung nicht gut findet das kann
ich verstehen aber wir haben die letzten
30 jahre globalisierung nicht die
strategie von jetzt auf gleich umdrehen
wenn wir uns langsam aus der
globalisierung verabschieden weil wir
sagen es kann nicht sein dass die
chinesen unsere antibiotika herstellen
wie wir jetzt in der pandemie gesehen
haben es kann nicht sein dass
bangladesch jeans produziert die nur 5
euro kosten die wir dann bei dicker max
für 20 weg auf das ist nicht richtig
wenn wir die globalisierung langsam dann
machen wir uns auch nicht mehr so
abhängig dann können wir auch an die
deutschen gasspeicher rangehen aber das
dauert jahre
jetzt sind wir in einem globalisierten
dorf jetzt müssen wir
sind wir
denken ja gewinnen und denke wir kommen
gern nach dänemark dänemark hat
biogasanlagen die haben 25 haben die ihr
eigenes gas und können damit ihre wärme
erzeugen 25 warum weil die 19 anlagen
haben in dänemark und von überall her
die wirtschaftlichen die
landwirtschaftlichen erzeugnisse holen
und auch was die industrielle abfälle
hat was lebensmittelmärkte an abfällen
hat und damit und damit bei 25 sind und
wann sein kleiner jahr 2004 unter ja
dann machen wir halt einfach mehr was
war bei uns mit dem biogas anlagen bei
uns konnte jeder kleine land wird das
haben bei sich was hat der gemacht der
hat misst gebracht und alles und hat das
damit gefüttert hat nicht gereicht dann
mais angebaut dann gras angebaut ein
weißes mag ist kein industrieland aber
keine rolle wir könnten aber mal voraus
schauen wir sind wir sind eigentlich wir
haben einfach nur gedacht okay monopol
das war natürlich auch die letzte
regierung muss ja auch wirklich sagen
muss man auch sagen wir haben einfach
gepennt hat es einfach aus der politik
ist ja nicht mehr gesehen
in eine richtung gelaufen also ich
glaube einfach nur inhalte her völlig
zustimmen langfristig müssen wir ja auch
aus den fossilen energien raus überhaupt
nichts sage dann wäre ich mehr abhängig
nur es gibt da technologisch immer noch
eine ganze reihe von ungelösten
problemen also ich finde auch dass wir
deutlich
unbürokratischer zum beispiel
solardächer fördern könnten also ich
kenne jetzt aus dem persönlichen
bekanntenkreis sie wollen jetzt ein
solardach es ist sowas von kompliziert
und deutschland das ist in anderen
ländern viel leichter also natürlich
könnte man viel mehr machen nur das
rettet unser nächsten winter nicht
aber man müsse wir haben eben auch der
vorschlag auch ein unterschied
deutschland ist eines der länder in
europa mit einer sehr starken industrie
das ist unser wohlstandsmodell also bei
uns sieht es eben nicht aus wie in
nordengland oder wie im rast bild von
den usa so zum glück sieht es bei uns
nicht aus auch italien hat sehr viel der
industrialisierten regionen
und ich meine wir müssen das mit aller
kraft verhindern dass auch bei uns eine
große demos realisierung hat findet und
ich meine auch weil sie vor in die nato
genannt haben die usa hat eine ganz
andere interessen lage also der gaspreis
in europa ist zurzeit neun mal so hoch
wie der in den usa das heißt die usa
machen natürlich irgendwo auch eigene
wirtschaftspolitik weil ihr standort
wird viel attraktiver dadurch wenn bei
uns die ex die energiekosten durch die
decke gehen und ich habe selber in
meinem umkreis wo ich wohne in merzig
macht gerade ein traditionsunternehmen
dicht wilde & boch nämlich die fliesen
fabrik weil sie sagen sie können sich
das nicht mehr leisten und die gehen zum
beispiel die türkei deswegen hatte ich
die vorhin erwähnt da ist es eben viel
billiger 200 leute die wieder ihren job
verlieren weil die arbeiter schlechter
bezahlt werden das auch aber das war
nicht der grund ich meine dieses werk
ist seit ewigen zeiten da audi in die
arbeit aber uns haben immer besser
verdient als in der türkei sondern es
ist jetzt die energiekosten differenz
die den ausschlag gegeben hat und so
gibt es eben ganz viele unternehmen und
ich finde da muss man einfach auch
pragmatische politik machen aber ich
kann so lange haben sie ja völlig recht
aber langfristig brauchen wir halten die
einmal das gedankenspiel würde ich gerne
mal mit ihnen beiden einmal durchspielen
sagen mir jetzt ich will jetzt nicht
anfangen was alles schlimmes in der
ukraine passiert ich finde dass das
immer etwas schwieriger debatte deswegen
spielen wir mal das gedankenspiel
deutschland sagt jetzt die sanktionen
sind vorüber würde putin ländern und
sofort die 5 prozent gas auch
wiedergeben oder man muss ja auch
überlegen wie man rhetorisch handelt
aber letztens eine spannende kolumne ich
glaube es war herr fleischhauer der
geschrieben hatte ja was was herr scholz
und herr putin da so reden was es für
ein signal auch gibt also wie würde das
jetzt ablaufen das frage ich gleich
welches signal würden wir auch herr
putin geben wenn deutschland jetzt
zurück weicht also wie könnt ihr das
alles funktionieren auch die
kommunikation
zurückweicht also ich meine es ist so
die eu hat den wirtschaftskrieg putin
hat den krieg in der ukraine begonnen
keine frage und das ist verbrecherisch
das ist glaube ich
wir haben darauf reagiert indem wir
einen immensen wirtschaftskrisen
getreten haben auf denen dann wiederum
auch russland schon wieder reagiert hat
und uns auch russland hat nicht den
wirtschaftskrieg begonnen und es ist
sehr unwahrscheinlich dass sie ihn von
sich aus führen würden also wenn wir
sagen die die sanktionen sind vorbei
also zum beispiel wenn deutschland jetzt
sagen würde ok werden lassen zur not
über nord stream 2 liefern dass wir
natürlich
das ist doch was heißt was er will er
machen ja auch so was er will er macht
ja was er will also der krieg wird
keinen tag früher beendet wenn wir die
sanktionen aufrecht erhalten das müssen
wir uns einfach klarmachen wer regiert
wird nur dann beendet
die waffen zu liefern
juli juli heißt der dem krieg benzin zu
geben den krieg anzuheizen ich verstehe
nicht wo die deutschen die
friedliebenden deutschen die
friedenspartei warum wir nicht
deeskalieren in hamburg an den großen g
7 treffen durften die polizisten keine
helme tragen dann habe ich gefragt warum
ja das ist die deeskalationsstrategie
bis die arme polizistin einen backstein
am kopf gekriegt hat dann durften sie
wieder helme tragen hier wäre die
deeskalationsstrategie angesagt aber
nein er würde nur davon die amerikaner
verkaufen fleißig waffen wir haben nicht
so viele wir werden beschimpft aber
unsere verteidigungsministerin wird
beschimpft obwohl sie sehr klug
gehandelt hat unser kanzler wird
beschimpft dass er nichts sagt reden
silber schweigen ist gold also ich würde
sagen mit diesem besonderen kanzler
haben wir sogar glück wir müssen sagen
dass wie sie richtiger es ist
illusorisch wir haben als deutsche
nichts zu reden wir können nur versuchen
unseren einfluss geltend zu machen in
der groß politischen lage und unser
ansprechpartner bitteschön ist
washington und nicht moskau denn es ist
washington die russland in die knie zu
bringen wollen und dafür muss die
ukraine erhalten und die ukrainischen
kämpfer müssen diesen es hat eine
abmachung sieht doch selbst dass
innerhalb hat in amerikaner folgenden
beispiel gesagt sie gehen in eine kneipe
rein ein amerikaner sieht mike tyson und
er möchte den mike tyson er hat ein
hühnchen mit ihm zurufen möchte ihm eine
rein schlagen traut sich aber nicht
sondern sagt den drei anderen männern
sie sollen ihm zeigen wie stark er ist
das ist der krieg in der ukraine und das
finde ich nicht gut und deswegen muss
frankreich und deutschland mit
engelszungen auf die amerikaner ein
reden und sagen leute wir kommen so
nicht weiter so in wales und auf dem
kühler teure jean lee chinesen wir haben
russland in die arme der chinesen
getrieben ohne not das ist weder
nachforschen aber diese sind doch eine
weltmacht aber das ist das ist unser
sagen wir mal dass du worüber wir
nachdenken sollten aber doch nicht
husten und zugleich so gar nicht in eine
frage stellen immer wenn leute hier sehr
stark für sanktionen waren und für
waffenlieferungen habe ich immer gefragt
ob sie auch an die front gehen würden
weil wenn man für das alles ist muss man
ja auch für den krieg seien würden sie
denn wenn sie jetzt sagen keine
sanktionen und auch keine
waffenlieferung wäre es seien auch für
sie in ordnung dass wir deutschen
eigentlich dann kein anteil daran nehmen
branche ukraine garcia das was die
vollmacht so viel wie möglich ukraine
aufnehmen und den ukrainern die
möglichkeit geben hier zu arbeiten
ich hatte nämlich vor zwei jahren eine
ukrainerin bei mir eine sehr fleißige
richter glauben sie dass die bei uns
eine arbeitsgenehmigung bekommen haben
haha ich konnte die arme dame nicht
anstellen die war tüchtig dann habe ich
den helmut schmidt im fernsehen gesehen
eine alte aufnahme da sagt er nämlich er
würde dringend raten wenn wir
arbeitskräfte brauchen brauche ich aber
die alte aus rheine holen und nicht aus
jährlich essen weil die ukraine uns
kulturell näher sind und dass weniger
konfliktstoff bringt also so genau aber
was in dem land passiert gebt uns
deutsche nichts an wenn ich sehr salopp
nein würde auch wieder aufbau
selbstverständlich wieder auf fahrt man
muss natürlich auch da helfen nur how
liefern wir haben als deutsche sehr viel
know how und wir haben vor allen dingen
als deutsche unsere pflicht der
diplomatie wir haben unseren bruder die
franzosen die sind noch viel bessere
diplomaten sich und die sarkozy und
angela merkel haben damals george hw
bush 2008 in bukarest gesagt wenn sie
und das wurde damals beschlossen dass
die ukraine teil der nato wird wenn die
ukraine teil der nato wird rasch einige
saßen erschlossen jetzt steht die in der
ukrainischen verfassung
da hat angela merkel und sarkozy gesagt
das ist eine kriegserklärung an russland
2008 wie viel wasser ist die donau
runter geflossen das wollte der westen
nicht hören die haben gedacht der russe
ist schwach den krieg war schon ali
haben die haben ja schon dann ist diese
idee fix dass man die russen
fertigmachen macht und das sehe ich
nicht ein weil das so lange nicht gegen
eine verwechslung verwöhn macht der
hunger frau merkels politik sagen dass
sie die russen fertig machen wollen dass
sie hat ja gesagt ja sie hat sich bei
george tabillion bush nicht durchsetzen
können mit sarkozy weil sie beide gesagt
haben es ist keine gute idee die ukraine
ist ein brücken land es soll neutral
bleiben vor dieser sensor lösung sind
wir jahrzehnte weg das vertrauen ist
kaputt das vertrauen ist verspricht es
wird ich werde eine vielleicht erlebe
ich es noch bis wir russland mit
russland wieder zu dieser beziehung
kommen wie wir sie mal habe es liegt
doch wissen dass da haben wir so viel
kaputt gemacht aber wir können jetzt
helfen doch etwas anders an wir können
es ist der krieg wird von uns geführt
meint auch er wurde angezettelt von
putin in berlin hat seine interessen
oder lässig diplom jahre wir wollen dass
die ukraine geschafft beschaffung bei
ihm nicht jeder hat es einen plan also
hitler ist seinen plan putin hat seinen
plan aber wir haben
die usa die nato hat beschlossen die
ukraine in die nato aufzunehmen
2008 da hat die kanzlerin damals und
sakura gewalt und gemerkt können doch
jetzt nicht wegen 2008 oder sie dürfen
das natürlich hier darf man alles aber
würden sie jetzt wegen 2008 die direkte
linie dazu ziehen dass du dir einen
angriffskrieg gemacht auch es wurde
gespielt er hat mehrere male gebeten mit
den amerikanern über minsk 1 um 12 zu
sprechen die amerikaner gesagt da reden
wir mit ihnen über gar nicht drüber das
war sicherlich richtig dass ich unsere
sind und nicht und gegraben haben die
mit einer fähre sind jährigen kultur
umspringen auch ob denn mit einem land
war also wie soll sich der wenig
womöglich einfach mimik die reden wir
nicht was hast du denn schon zu erzählen
desto geben und somit nicht der kommerz
damit jeder seine redezeit hier bekommt
einmal zu
und sie dürfen jetzt mit ihrem plädoyer
dass ich auch schon vorher sehr gerne
gelesen habe das gar nicht alles so
schwarz man sitzt er hier an diesem
tisch und merkt bei einem thema gibt es
viele meinungen zum glück haben wir das
ist auch in deutschland
ein plädoyer
ich habe eigentlich gar kein platt wie
ich bin einfach nur und tatkräftiger
mensch ich bin die praktikerin für
möglicherweise bei ganz vielen
theoretikern weil ich im endeffekt
einfach zu packen wenn irgendwas ist ich
habe auch eine ukrainerin die habe ich
seit märz das heißt sie habe ich aber
nicht weil ich eine ukrainerin aufnehmen
wollte sondern ich habe mich geärgert
dass die
ukrainerinnen ihre haustiere bis zur
grenze mitschleppen manchmal große
schäferhunde um die zu retten und kaum
sind sehr in den deutschen
aufwarten angekommen müssen die tiere in
das tierheim also habe ich gesagt ich
nehme haustiere auf und ich nehme den
haustieren die entsprechendes das
frauchen auf egal wer jetzt kommt und
dann kam eben natalia mit zwei hunden
und ihre tochter mit einer katze und so
kam das aus seiner thalia hat eine hat
eine ballettschule in
kiew und ist es natürlich online
verbunden hat auch ihre eine
ballettschülerinnen bei mir hat sie auch
da trainiert und jetzt waren sie bei der
weltmeisterschaft in san sebastian und
haben bei der weltmeisterschaft den
vierten platz geholt da bin ich richtig
stolz auf meine oder auf meine
ukrainerinnen denn die anderen die
konkurrenz sie hatte natürlich große
ballettschulen haben da richtig
üben können und meine hat bei mir im
wohnzimmer geübt also von dem her
gesehen denke ich immer wenn wir etwas
tun können können uns jetzt im moment
für die menschen tun denn auch natalia
möchte natürlich zurück alle wollen
zurück aber alle wollen natürlich nicht
dass ihnen eine bombe aufs haus fällt
und bei ihr in kiew war es jetzt genau
so dass 500 megabyte eine rakete
eingeschlagen hat und das finde ich
eigentlich das dramatische dass wir
menschen sitzen sie auf einen knopf
drücken und gar nicht mehr wissen wenn
es dann am schluss eigentlich trifft und
dann weiß ich auch nicht wie das mit dem
wiederaufbau sein soll denn wenn jetzt
aufgebaut wird wo soll aufgebaut werden
und bisher ist ja noch gar nichts
befriedet wir wissen ja noch gar nicht
was putin noch weiter vorhat wieder dann
vom donders praktisch nachdem er dann
diese seite für sich eingenommen hat
wunderschön dann praktisch ins land
vormarschieren männer dann diese länge
hat werden wir schauen ja in seinen kopf
nicht rein leider das wäre natürlich
wunderschön ich gleich jetzt immer so
ein bisschen wie wenn jetzt in
deutschland einmarschiert werden würde
und man sagt jetzt okay es geben hat die
bayern hat mal ab weil die haben ja auch
zwei grenzen tschechien und
unterstreichen rosenberger aber
wunderbar unterlaufen bis am boden die
rheinländer wieder keine abgeben
vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht
wie man es doch auch wehren und würden
dann auch sagen hier leute wir wollen
die beiden aber doch behalten und wir
kämpfen nicht und die bayern
und von dem er gesehen aber denke ich
ist es geht eben auch so land tirol und
südtirol auch damals wurde die grafische
sie rola werden gerne
ewig weiter man kosovo-albaner wollten
ihre autonomie haben und haben diese
autonomie auch bekommen und es gibt
gewisse länder die haben die
kosovo-albaner anerkannt und andere
länder auch nicht also diese
autonomiebestrebungen haben wir überall
und das gehört ja zur demokratie
das die leute selber sagen dürfen zu wem
sie gehört oder dürfen sie jetzt halt
gerade nicht in der ukraine ist halt im
moment was das angeht nein nicht in das
stimmt so nicht und europas im dom was
die das gebiet was die russen jetzt
erobern wollen
dort hat sich die bevölkerung weil sie
auch russischsprachige sind und sich
sehr viel mit rund 14 prozent genau das
dass das system versagt nicht alle
allgäuer also so überlastet oder wo sie
an sich das
vorgehen der creme haben sie abgestimmt
da war hat man ja eindeutig gesehen was
sie wollen und jetzt dort las man sie
doch auch abstürze kommen und vielleicht
will ja auch lemberg und der west
ukraine wollen vielleicht wieder zurück
nach polen könnte auch sein bleiben
werde als und alle alten grenzen
man kommt man rein
das werden sollte da natürlich nicht
schön das ist unrecht wenn ein land ein
anderes silberfeld und grenzen
verschieden überhaupt keine frage aber
die frage ist ja was passiert dann was
macht man dann kann man das verhindern
kann man es hätte man es vielleicht im
vorhinein verhindern können wir machen
also ich glaube dadurch war die bessere
diplomatie und politik diesen ganzen
flug verfluchten krieg der schon so
viele menschenleben gekostet hätte
verhindern können so das ist jetzt
vergessen nämlich aber es ist trotzdem
der relevante frage weil das auch mit
verantwortung heißt aber wenn man ihn
schon nicht verhindern konnte wie kann
man jetzt möglichst schnell das sterben
beenden und natürlich ist es auch nicht
die einzige region auf dieser welt die
die besetzt wird auch in den letzten
jahren nicht mehr also die usa zum
beispiel besetzen bis heute die
syrischen ölfelder große teile davon das
finden die völlig normal die haben jetzt
noch mal da irgendwie so ein wort
umgebaut und schaffen das öl weg die
türkei besetzt und wird auch immer
wieder kriegerisch tätig sowohl in
syrien als auch im nordirak überfällt da
einfach bestimmte regionen keiner sagt
dass große relativierungen das ist nicht
weiter sondern dass eine zeigen also von
das andere doch auch mal was hierzu aus
ihrer partei geführt hat sie ihre
haltung dass man diese verhandlungen
diese gespräche jetzt aufnehmen muss und
sollte und ein nein nein nein schallte
ihnen dahingegen ja ich trete hier nicht
die position meiner partei ich vertrete
meine position
einige hier zu sagen wenn nur
deutschland bereit ist vielleicht mit
frankreich zusammen den schalter
umzulegen dann wird das alles gut und
auch nie gesagt
das seien alles versauen und was mich
nervt also wie gesagt das ist keine
relativierung nur ich finde man sollte
nicht so tun als ob der einzige
grauenvolle verbrecherische krieg seit
dem ende des zweiten weltkriegs in der
ukraine stattfinden ob das einzige grobe
unrecht wo mit waffengewalt gebiete und
grenzen verschoben werden in der ukraine
stattfindet das stimmt nicht es gab ganz
viele kriege gerade auch in den letzten
jahren gerade auch unter führung der usa
aber hat er haben wir auch nie mit
sanktionen reagiert
leider naturell des menschen umso näher
es beim ist im freundeskreis betrifft
seien deswegen möchte ich auf den krieg
hinweisen unser freunde unser
gemeinsamer freunde prinz asserate der
in frankfurt lebt hat mich gestern
darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass in seinem
krieg in seinem land äthiopien der
schlimmste kriegt und jetzt seit 3000
jahren
die bringen im massenmorden in der
frankfurter allgemeine haben sie so viel
text darüber das ist wirklich zum weinen
in der schlimmste krieg sagt er seit
3000 jahren ein altes kulturvolk wo sich
zwei natürlich wird es auch von
irgendjemandem mitfinanzierte wissen
nicht wer ich weiß es nie wer dahinter
steckt aber er sagt
abgeschlachtet auf als über tausende von
menschen und glas wieder überhaupt nicht
darüber sprechen sie sprechen gerade
aber das ist nicht weit ist es neben
angefangen wir sind doch während der
globalisierung ununterbrochen nach
südafrika gefahren nach indien gefahren
nach amerika gewarnt das ist viel weiter
weg als äthiopien ist nächstes möchte
das nicht relativieren jetzt mit ihr bin
ich finde es ganz schlimm auch wenn das
nirgendwo berichtet wird ich habe leider
auch noch nichts darüber aktuell gelesen
dementsprechend gebe ich ihm recht aber
dieser krieg in europa da ist man ja
schon auch als deutscher aufgewacht und
konnte es kaum fassen dass er wieder
krieg in europa haben weil wir nicht auf
die kanzlerin weil die kanzlerin und
sarkozy weil man nicht ihnen geholfen
hat wahrscheinlich hat damals die presse
auch wieder geschimpft dass sie nicht zu
hören dass george hw bush dass er recht
hat und man muss jetzt streng sein bei
der man muss ja durchsetzen was wahrheit
ist leute ich noch letzte woche
berg stehen nach außen zeigen nur mit
stärke können wir denen da müssen wir
jetzt richtig ran solch eine rhetorik
von deutschland ausgerechnet deutsche
und ausgerechnet die grünen unsere
friedenspartei die leute die bäume
umrahmen also leute wir müssen wieder
nüchtern werden wir müssen wieder sagen
die deutschen und die franzosen wir
haben im großen spiel der weltmächte
sowieso kein wirkliches zünglein an der
wir haben wir sind wir sind conti
penible muss man leider sagen wir sind
gegen könnten einfluss nehmen weil wir
charmante politikerinnen haben
jetzt müssen sie meine ganze reihe
v wagen weg zum beispiel aber auch
unsere frau bär burg kannte könnte wenn
man hier die rentenzahlung clauder
tasche die ist
dieser berg guten job ja aber sieht man
müsste hier nur sagen was sie sagen soll
jetzt ist sieht geeicht worden darauf
müsse das sei mit dem russen man sie
soll deren charme einsetzen und die
vier musiker washington verhandelt das
sind unsere partner
wir sind diejenigen die die waffen
liefern wir sind diejenigen die gas
geben in diesem krieg wir sind
diejenigen die anschieben macht weiter
macht weiter das muss zu ende sein wir
müssen wieder normal wenn wir müssen
sagen wir wollen keinen krieg und schon
gleich gar nicht mit dem ukrainer weil
die uns am herzen liegen weil uns die
bilder dieser zerstörten häuser stören
weil uns die massen von menschen die
kommen und nach hause wollen wir
ertragen ist nicht bitte hört auf ihr
habt doch auch in afghanistan aufgehört
habt eure ganzen spielsachen dagelassen
die chinesen sich einfach genommen haben
und jetzt schön nachbauen ihr habt doch
auch in afghanistan eure sachen einfach
stehen lassen
wo die autorin die nation
nicht gewöhnt aber frau hauptmann konnte
die füßchen sie denn diese man kann sich
einerseits leidenschaftliches plädoyer
man überzeugen nein aber
weil für mich ist es ja immer noch so
dass ist es das ist wunderbar aber
wer geht denn jetzt eigentlich zu herrn
putin und sagt okay jetzt es hat ja
schon jeder versucht
das ganze angezettelt hat beinahe
in drehen wenn wir zurückschauen gebe
ich ihnen völlig recht dass wir da
fehler gemacht haben ganz
hundertprozentig wir haben ja gerade
schon mal so nebenher gesagt eben auch
diese diese aussage von obama das ist ja
nur eine russische provinz oder so dann
halt nach einem regional macht er das
waren sicherlich kränkungen und kleine
männer mit großen hunden haben probleme
mit kränker ja es kann man kann sich so
einfach machen aber es gab auch leute
wie horst teltschik immerhin der
gefeierte architektin der deutschen
einheit der langjährige chef für mich
eine sicherheitskonferenz der in einem
interview schon nach ausbruch des
krieges um die ukraine gesagt hat es war
ein fehler dass wir nach der
sicherheitskonferenz damals vielleicht
mehr putin dort zum letzten mal zu gast
war in münchen und seine sorgen und auch
seine drohung öffentlich gemacht hat
nicht darauf eingegangen sind so was
versandet natürlich völlig untätig ist
ja wirklich nicht im verdacht irgendwie
russen freundlich oder dergleichen zu
sein so dass das unheil sich aufbaut und
irgendwann dann dann platzt das und
jetzt wollte halt eben auch mal zeigen
wie gesagt kränkungen sind sind
und frauchen trotzdem ich glaube auch
mit italien und wem auch immer zusammen
hier
gemeinsam sich an einen tisch setzen
könnten mit wladimir putin um den großen
frieden oder das aufheben der sanktionen
zu erreichen das halte ich für so was
von illusorisch gerade nach den
entwicklungen die wir gesehen haben hier
braucht es dann eine einen gesamte
strand aber jetzt nur zwei verschiedene
dinge also den krieg zu beenden da
braucht dass die usa haben die sagen in
der zonen aufzugeben nicht nur allein
dort soll die länder die sich an den
sanktionen nicht beteiligen haben mit
russland normale wirtschaftsbeziehungen
da liefern die ihr lager liefern dealen
sie liefern auch wie gesagt in die
türkei sie liefern auch nach ungarn sie
liefern an all die länder die jetzt
sagen sie wollen gerne kaufen und sie
machen da nicht mit also das ist ja
schon so also wieder was die auch nicht
verstanden habe das ist tatsächlich so
dass ist die strategie die wir haben
seit anfang der sanktionen zu sagen ja
wir bestrafen die ich wladimir putin
nicht auch von unserer außenministerin
und auch in unserem wirtschaftsminister
und wir drehen der das gas ab und wir
stoßen auch die öllieferung auf null
aber vorher machst du uns noch mal die
gasspeicher voll ich das ist ja das ist
natürlich
nicht mehr kauft wir wollen nicht mehr
kaufen aber vorher noch mal voll machen
dass das ohne folgen bleibt ist
natürlich genauso klar dass das nicht
funktionieren könne das würde auch jeder
unternehmer also nehme an ich bin
unternehmer und will einen lieferanten
loswerden weil der mir irgendwie zu
anstrengend ist ja dann gehe ich doch
nicht erst erstes sehen sagt dem
lieferanten also dich werde ich auf
jeden fall ab nächstes jahr werde ich
nichts mehr von dirk aber ich hab noch
gar keinen anderen wäre mir was liefern
dann guckt man sich doch vorher um was
haben wir für alternativen mal hätte man
natürlich auch bei erneuerbaren sicher
manches mehr machen können man hätte
vielleicht auch in andere richtungen
gucken können wo man alternative hat
wenn sie bezahlbar sind und wenn wir sie
haben dann hätten wir auch sagen okay
dann reduzieren wir die russischen
lieferungen aber was die deutsche
regierung gemacht hat war einfach
kompletter wahnsinn also sie haben im
grunde angekündigt ende des jahres
wollen sie auch wie das russische öl
nicht mehr und das weiß ich nicht ein
paar jahren und dann gehen sie davon aus
aber bis dahin liefern die brav
möglichst auch noch zu den guten alten
verträgen mit sehr niedrigen preisen das
war ja ist ja tatsächlich immer
wirtschaftsaufschwung ist dank der
niedrigen preise
prüfung zusammenbricht